[Music]
hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is about my keep it simple 1d
for a repertoire I'm going to give you a
quick overview how this repertoire is
constructed what's the idea behind it
and what are some key points of this
approach of playing 1d for so after 1d
form a main challenge for widest if you
compile a repertoire to be aware of all
the different move orders that black may
play so playing things in the right
order is very much important for white
because black is rather flexible in his
order of moves they can for example
start with e six Knight f6 or d5 if they
want a setup that includes all the three
moves so they could start with any of
the three and in any case you have to be
kind of ready for what's coming in the
next couple of moves so you have to for
example here decide do you want to
commit the knight here because they
could play six they could also play g6
next or d5 or c5 or whatever and this is
very much important to understand this
is far less of an issue with 1e form
where the options that black has are
vastly reduced also there is no
transposition almost no transposition if
you play E for let's say and they play
e5 or c5 this is never going to
transpose into one another you have kind
of set of lines for each reply and that
is kind of not connected to one another
and that is not the case with D form for
example after d4 they could play d5 for
a Dutch and then you decide to play move
let's say you decide to play this and
they could also do this and then you
play this and they play a five and then
you wonder hey didn't I want to play
this in front of the C pawn and then you
already move on it so you need to be
very much aware of all those move autumn
ideas now the solution to this is at
least the solution that I'm
um suggesting is to have a set of moves
that we're going to play as a default
let's say so we only need to look at
exceptions to this predefined set of
moves I suggest to basically play no
matter what black does we're going to
play the moves g3 next like this and
they play let's say this and we play
Bishop g2 and then we usually castle and
play c4 in most cases later
so I'm saying you go d4 and you're free
and keto and there are only very few
exceptions to this the only exceptions
really are black playing something bad
that we can immediately exploit like b5
for example it's better to play if I
don't play data three there in those
cases we should take the center and be
happy or another exception that's the
second one is black playing stuff like
c5 the Benoni
where there's no good way to play g3 we
should play d5 and be happy about the
space same applies for Knight f6 Knight
f3 c5 d 5 this is also generally rather
good for white and we should be happy to
take the space in all other cases the g3
based setup is what I recommend and then
you're already are pretty sure what
you're going to do that the first five
or six moves and then of course there
will be differences it's of course
different if black plays with d5 or with
g6 but you have certain similarities in
your setups and this way you have
avoided much of mainstream theory that
is going to be others would be a big
theoretical workload on you one example
for this is if black plays a d5 based
setup if you play in a more classical
way with c4 first they could for example
take and this is rather a lot of theory
to learn it's really surprising maybe
but it is not easy to play against the
qga or more importantly if you plan to
play g3 for Catalan they could take here
and after Bishop g2 they have like six
different moves that they can play and
they're all complicated so I'm simply
suggesting to play g3 before c4 and say
ok I'm going to make it more convenient
me I'm just going to castle first and
then I play c4 and then the capture is
far less of an issue in terms of
theoretical work now this is just the
main line um
this kind of approach is of course not
coming without a price tag there is a
small price tag to that and this is
black can try to exploit the fact that
we haven't played c4 early on and those
ideas are indeed interesting but I'm
simply saying that black might know that
these ideas exist but if you are an
expert and playing against that and
really know what you're doing you
shouldn't be afraid of that because we
can still post many problems often Lex
knowledge will be sketchy for example a
line that is often quoted as being okay
for black is this one where black
prevents c4 now my point is people first
of all don't know that all that much
it's not something that is common
knowledge and everybody would just flame
but the second point is people might
know that b5 is okay and it is okay I'm
not saying it's a bad move but they
don't know much more after that and this
is for example what I knew before I
wrote this course I even played be 5 in
a tournament game against the 2,200
player but after b5 my knowledge was
over I didn't know anything more and in
fact in this game my opponent didn't
test me but if he would have known what
I know now I would have been in trouble
I'm for sure I'm sure
like after this I recommend for example
the sequence of moves and now with black
hue kind of have to know that you should
play c5 I still think that this is a bit
better for white but if you take here
which is the most natural move after
Knight takes this is difficult for black
and in fact you will see if you look at
my course I think that black now works
really a tightrope already to not be
quite worse so there are many many
pitfalls in those supposedly good lines
that if you know them with white then
you can still pose lots of problems and
you are on your territory not on the
opponent's territory so what your what
the opponent's busy is trying to say
okay you play sideline I want to really
take use of that but they are not able
in
reasonably short amount of time to out
prepare you if you know these lines well
you will still be able to pose many
problems a very recent example actually
from yesterday from that yesterday from
them today there was a game in the
Norway chess tournament when ding-ding
the rent played my repertoire it was
funny to see he played exactly a line
that I'm suggesting and black was karana
and Kawana went for this setup I guess
he was certainly surprised that this was
on the board it's not a commonly seen
opening on the top level and the move
Queen c7
I'm sure caranas main point was okay I'm
preventing c4 here right so that must be
a good idea now b3 played by ding and
then Keira wanna play d5 only to be hit
now
with the move c4 takes and Bishop b2
and this is actually a novelty that now
ding can claim and I already had it in
my course no words for I think roughly 2
months and I knew that this was good for
white and Khurana now spent 25 minutes
but ultimately he grabbed this and he
basically has to regret this Queen takes
and now black was under huge pressure
because white has such a great
development and Khurana didn't manage to
save the game so this is actually an
example on the highest level Khurana and
you that this is an interesting idea
maybe but he didn't know it's deep
enough he didn't know that this is a
good pawn sacrifice and will actually
put black under pressure and this is a
common scenario that have experienced in
my blitz games and games were tried out
the repertoire there people sometimes
know okay this is kind of reasonable but
they don't know it well and this is a
the chance for you so I think this is a
great way to play with white the whole
fianchetto setups by the way they
provide much safety yeah you are
absolutely safe with your King and you
can play um somewhat more positional
game that is something that is usually
the game that the default players look
four people are interested in default
it's kind of more of a buildup than
trying to be a heck quickly speaking of
hacking
there are also some sharp lines in the
repertoire mostly in cases where black
is very ambitious and in these some kind
of cases we have to fight fire with fire
this is also what you would see in the
free one-hour video snippet that is um
free to download as a as an appetizer
that's one of the coolest lines in the
whole repertoire with the entire
cigarette alright so I hope you enjoyed
the quick overview about keep it simple
one default course um go get it on on
chasuble um I really think it's a great
way to play with white and very happy to
test it out myself
you know I already did before the
release but I think I always did it a
little bit yeah in hiding you don't want
to give out all your ideas and now I can
freely play it as it is publicly
available yeah thanks for watching the
video
[Music]